حيث
يلتقي المحيط الأطلسي بالبحر الشمالي ، غالبًا ما يكون الطقس
دراماتيكيًا
دائمًا ما يتغير حيث
يتدحرج فوق شتلاند مجموعة من الجزر البريطانية على بعد
حوالي 100 ميل
شمال البر الرئيسي الاسكتلندي في هذا
المكان الجميل النائي ، تبدو المناظر الطبيعية الخام
والقوية
تشتهر هذه التلال العاصفة
غالبًا ما
تتم مشاركة المهور الصغيرة المشاكسة هذه المياه مع
الحيوانات المفترسة الرئيسية
، وفي فصل الربيع ، يمكن أن يؤدي انفجار في القطب الشمالي إلى تغطية
كل شيء للطائرات المؤرضة وتأخير
مهمة منقذة للحياة في جزر شيتلاند
،
ويحكم الطقس كل
ذلك بما في ذلك الجهود المبذولة لإطلاق
لقاح فيروس كورونا في
نهاية المطاف في السماء  واضح وتم
إطلاق عملية لحماية
واحدة من المجتمعات الأكثر عزلة في المملكة المتحدة
من المستشفى الوحيد في المنطقة ، حيث
يتم إرسال الجرعات
إلى المطار وترافقها الممرضة مارغريت كوبر ،
وتتمثل مهمتها في توزيع اللقاح في
مكان غير عادي في
جزيرة عادلة على مسافة إسفين صغيرة من  الأرض
محاطة بالمحيطات المفتوحة المنحدرة شديدة
الانحدار والحقول المنحدرة أكثر  من عدد قليل من الأغنام
وهذا كل شيء
يعيش الناس هنا 45 شخصًا فقط
سرعان ما نراهم يتقدمون
متقاربين في المبنى الصغير المستخدم كمكتب
طبي حيث تعمل مارغريت كوبر
وتأتي بمقعد
مزيج قوي من الدفء الممتع كل ذلك
أفضل لهذا اليوم المجيد
ولا توجد كفاءة هراء خدش
حاد خدش خدش حاد ، ها
نحن
ذا ، هذا أنت وسكان
Fair Isle ممتنون لما
تشعر به اليوم آه الشمس
تشرق
بعد أسبوع من الثلج لدينا
اللقاحات الثانية ، لذا ، نعم ، جيد جدًا ،
على عكس بقية المملكة المتحدة ،
يحصل الجميع هنا على التطعيم
في نفس الوقت
بغض النظر عن العمر ، سعيد جدًا بالحصول على
الوظيفة الثانية وامتيازًا للغاية لأنه
على الرغم من شعري الرمادي ، فأنا لست بهذا العمر
لجميع الأسباب الواضحة ، أصبحت الحياة هنا
منعزلة ،
ولكن بشكل خاص أثناء الوباء
لأكثر من عام
، ظلت الجزيرة العادلة مغلقة إلى حد كبير أمام
العالم ،
ولكن حتى هنا هناك خوف من
الفيروس حسنًا ، إنه خوف أكبر بطريقة معينة لأنه إذا جاء إلى هنا ، فقد يكون مدمرًا ، فقد ينتشر مثل حريق في الهشيم قضى جيمي ستاوت معظم سنواته الـ 77 في الجزيرة ، لقد كان هادئًا للغاية لقد كان الأمر كما كان عندما كنت نشأ طفل هنا ونحن معتادون على السياحة الآن والناس يأتون ويذهبون ولكن كان الأمر هادئًا جدًا حيث كان الحصول على الجرعات هنا أمرًا صعبًا ولكن حقنهم في الذراعين لا يستغرق سوى بضع ساعات في مجتمع صغير بعيد هش ومحدود تتمتع المرافق الطبية الآن ببعض راحة البال ، يعد تومي هيدمان واحدًا من آخر الأشخاص الذين انتقلوا إلى هنا من شمال نيويورك قبل 15 عامًا ، هناك أشخاص في جميع أنحاء العالم يريدون بشدة هذا اللقاح ولكن ها نحن في جزيرة عادلة وقد حصلت عليه أعتقد أنه أمر مثير للإعجاب لأنني اعتقدت أنه من العدل أن أكون آخر مكان على الإطلاق يحصل فيه برنامج لقاح بريطانيا على قصة نجاح جائحة نادر ، لكن الأمر يتعلق بأكثر من مجرد تأمين جرعات كافية  إنجاز مبني من خلال
القوة التنظيمية
لخدمة الصحة الوطنية جنبًا
إلى جنب مع
العلاقات ، تجربة الموظفين المحليين الملتزمين
الآن جيمي ، هل كان لديك أي آثار جانبية
بعد آخر مرة قالت
مارجريت كوبر إنه
الفصل الأكثر
فخرًا في مسيرتها المهنية التي امتدت لـ 50 عامًا ، إنه
امتياز  لتكون قادرًا على أن تكون جزءًا من
برنامج التطعيم
وتشعر بأنك تساهم
مساهمة حاسمة في عملية غير
مسبوقة
تنقذ الأرواح وتستعيد
الحريات
في كل مكان في المملكة المتحدة
.